INTRO:
Over the past few decades, tech has transitioned
from being a luxury consumer product to a
necessity.
From easy access to information and savings
in time, energy and effort to mobility, safety,
and of course entertainment.
There's no doubt that tech has become an integral
part of all of our lives today, and that it’s
pros far outweigh its cons.
But, when we’re so dependent on a set of
products, it becomes very important to protect
the source.
Luckily, there’s thousands of tech companies
today and dozens of competitors in each sector,
so even if some companies went under, we would
have plenty of options to choose from right?
Well, even though there’s thousands of tech
companies, there’s only a handful of companies
that manufacture all the tech with the most
prominent one being Foxconn.
Foxconn is a Taiwanese contract manufacturer
who assembles 40% of all global consumer electronics.
Basically every tech company you can think
of works with Foxconn including Apple, Amazon,
Dell, Google, Intel, Microsoft, and everyone
else.
But, despite their dominance, the ethics and
morality of the company are much more questionable.
So, here’s how Foxconn became the modern
day plantation that we can’t live without.
TERRY GOU:
Taking a look back, the story of Foxconn circles
back to a man named Terry Gou who was born
in Taipei County on October 18, 1950.
His parents were originally from mainland
China, but they had fled to Taiwan near the
end of the Chinese Civil War.
In Taiwan, Terry’s father continued his
career as a police officer while Terry worked
his way through school.
With entrepreneurs, we often see polar ends
of the spectrum when it comes to education.
Either they dropped out of school to start
a business or they got a PhD from MIT.
But, Terry was a middle of the road student.
He would end up attending Taipei University
of Marine Technology where he got his bachelors.
It’s not clear what Terry majored in, but
it doesn’t seem to be too influential to
his career as Terry ended up getting a low
level job at a rubber factory following college.
For most of his early 20s, Terry found himself
working many such jobs, but despite his low
wages, Terry was slowly able to build up some
capital thanks to his frugality.
By the time he was 24, Terry had saved up
$7500 which he would use to start Hon Hai.
Terry manufactured plastic TV parts which
had quite a bit of demand, but it wasn’t
glamorous by any means.
Hon Hai was originally run out of a rented
shed in Tucheng, and the staff consisted of
10 elderly workers who probably weren’t
able to find jobs anywhere else due to their
age.
Despite the rough start, the TV parts were
enough to make ends meet until Terry received
his first breakthrough order.
In 1980, Atari would ask Hon Hai to manufacture
their console joystick, and this would motivate
Terry to travel to the US and try to acquire
more western buyers.
Terry commonly arrived at company headquarters
uninvited, and as you would guess, he had
security called on him many times.
Terry wasn’t phased by these experiences
though, and he would continue to hustle his
way into HQs and secure a couple of contracts
by the time he returned to Taiwan.
These new western contracts substantially
helped Hon Hai’s financials, but this new
link with American companies was just the
beginning.
FOXCONN:
In 1988, Terry would purchase the company’s
first formal factory in Shenzhen China.
Since then, Terry has purchased and built
dozens of factories around the world, but
this original factory is still one of his
largest.
Anyway, in 1996, Terry would get a contract
from Compaq to manufacture desktop chassis.
This quickly grew into contracts with HP and
IBM as well, but the nail in the coffin didn’t
come till 2000 when Foxconn inked a deal with
Apple.
Foxconn had already manufactured parts for
Apple in the past, but this time, they were
contracted to produce the iMac itself.
This project not only changed Foxconn’s
balance sheet, but it permanently changed
the quality of their manufacturing.
As we all know, Apple has high quality standards,
and meeting these standards was a prerequisite
to continue working with Apple.
Meeting Apple’s quality standards wasn’t
easy though because it wasn’t just a case
of sourcing high quality materials and ensuring
excellent consistency.
In many cases, Foxconn had to invent new manufacturing
procedures to make Apple’s slick design
aesthetic a reality.
While this was often quite challenging, this
helped Foxconn make a name for themselves
in the manufacturing space.
They were no longer just another Asian manufacturer
that competed based on price.
They were turning into the go to manufacturer
if you wanted customizability and quality.
And this new role would really be put to the
test with the launch of the iPhone.
Between 2009 and 2012, Apple went from accounting
for 25% of Foxconn’s revenue to a peak of
55%.
Also, don’t forget, Apple was actually regularly
changing the iPhone’s design during this
time period, so keeping up with exploding
demand and constantly evolving design was
extremely challenging.
But, by the time Foxconn got to the other
side of the mobile adoption curve, they were
one of the most desirable manufacturers in
the world.
Foxconn was receiving orders from every tech
company you can think of, and Foxconn’s
revenue exploded from $40 billion in 2009
to $140 billion by 2016.
In the meantime, Terry was using all these
new found profits to acquire company’s left
and right.
But behind the scenes, the story of Foxconn
was completely different.
THE TECH PLANTATION:
One of the biggest reasons that most people
have never heard about Foxconn is not because
they’re underrated, but because they actively
try to fly under the radar.
You see, the working conditions at Foxconn
aren’t particularly pleasant, and the less
media attention they can get, the better.
First of all, most factory workers live at
the factories.
On the brightside, this means that employees
don’t have to spend any money on housing,
food, recreation, and other basic amenities
as all of these are taken care of by Foxconn.
Foxconn has gotten a bit more stingy over
the years forcing employees to pay for things
such as laundry, but for the most, if you’re
a Foxconn employee, your cost of living is
extremely low.
The problem though is that unless you’re
sleeping, eating, or performing other basic
day to day functions, you’re working.
This means 12 hour shifts 6 days a week if
not 7 days a week.
Employees aren’t allowed to talk to each
other, and they get a 10 minute bathroom break
every 2 hours.
Apple actually received a lot of backlash
for these working conditions in the early
2010s, and they worked with Foxconn to reduce
these hours to 60 hours per week.
But really, this doesn’t mean much.
Sure, Foxconn employees are only required
to work 60 hours a week, but given that most
of them are in terrible financial situations,
they’re desperate to work all the overtime
they can which leads to 12 hour shifts once
again.
At least, they’re getting paid for the overtime,
but again, this doesn’t really mean much
either.
As of November 2021, the average Foxconn employee
was receiving a base monthly salary of a whopping
$314 before deductions.
Even if we assume that this only includes
40 hours of work per week, we’re looking
at just $1.96 per hour.
If we assume a more realistic 60 hours per
week, we’re looking at $1.30 per hour.
After mandatory deductions, taxes, and pension
payments, this drops to a net take home income
of a measly 98 cents per hour.
But terrible working conditions and pay are
just scratching the surface.
THE ETHICAL BORDER:
Despite basically operating a tech plantation,
Foxconn is not breaking any laws.
They follow all the minimum wage and worker
requirements laid out by China and Taiwan.
But, this doesn’t mean that they aren’t
crossing ethical boundaries.
Aside from it being immoral to pay employees
$2 per hour and letting them work till exhaustion,
the most unethical result of Foxconn’s work
culture is literally death.
No asian Foxconn factory worker chooses to
work there because they want to.
Usually, people apply to Foxconn because they
have no choice, and this is their last means
of survival.
But unfortunately, many would rather just
not live at all than continue working at Foxconn.
Starting in 2010, dozens of factory workers
started jumping off the factory buildings,
and this issue actually got so common that
Foxconn had to install nets on the sides of
their buildings to reduce deaths.
I don’t think I have to say anything else
about Foxconn’s work culture.
Foxconn’s work environment isn’t the only
toxic part of their business either.
Their business itself is literally toxic both
to workers and the environment.
It’s no secret that loads of toxic materials
and chemicals are used in the production of
electronics.
Between 2010 and 2014, 13 workers under the
age of 20 developed leukemia.
Many have speculated that this is due to the
employees coming into contact with Benzene
in the factories, but Foxconn has repeatedly
denied this asserting that there is no contact
with Benzene.
Even if this is true though, given the non
negligible number of leukemia cases, it seems
like Foxconn does play some role in this.
Moving onto their environmental impact, their
most obvious form of pollution is of course
air pollution.
Running their factories requires a lot of
energy which in turn leads to a lot of air
pollution.
Foxconn has been working on installing solar
panels and transitioning to renewable energy,
but this is still in the early stages.
Switching to renewable energy wouldn’t clean
Foxconn though as a large portion of their
pollution is water pollution.
Many of their factories draw water from nearby
lakes and rivers to use in the manufacturing
process.
And then, they dump their polluted chemical
water back into the same lakes and rivers
ruining local environments and potentially
poisoning nearby residents.
So while Foxconn may not be breaking any legal
boundaries, their stance on ethical boundaries
is a lot more questionable.
SUPPLY SHORTAGE:
Activists have tried to fight back against
Foxconn’s ethical issues for years now,
but it’s been difficult to make any real
progress.
The supply shortage, however, is causing change.
The shortage has revealed the brutal reality
of relying so heavily on one company for the
world’s consumer tech.
Foxconn’s clients are pushing Foxconn to
diversify outside of Asia, and they’re contracting
out more and more work to other manufacturers.
While this doesn’t directly address the
ethical concerns regarding Foxconn, it does
indirectly solve many of these issues.
For example, western countries have much stricter
policies when it comes to worker’s rights,
minimum wage, and pollution.
So, hopefully Foxconn’s business will become
cleaner as they diversify into western countries,
but only time will tell.
As for Terry, he’s currently 71 years old
and he still serves as the CEO and chairman
of Foxconn.
He currently ranks in the top 500 richest
people in the world coming in at $6.15 billion.
It’s a bit ironic that he’s only worth
$6 billion given that his company is the lifeblood
of many trillion dollar companies, but then
again, he only pays his employees $2 per hour,
so maybe he doesn’t even deserve this in
the first place.
Do you guys think Terry deserves his wealth?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you think that Foxconn
employees should be paid way better.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.